this very I'm bringing in more deaths of
each summer confirmed by like blood some
of them are confirmed by leaked photos
file summer own supported by few
theories of mine in part one I
introduced with the night Kings master
plan the tool eventual result with
Circe's and Jaime's death and even
possibly with the death of Jon Snow in
that video I explained you have all main
characters in Game of Thrones as well as
all of us fans expect the great battle
to be fought in the north on a throne
defined by the advance of the army of
the diadem partly we are correct the
north will face a hundred thousand
strong army white walkers and her whites
but a knight king of five is errant the
far south across the old Westeros and
will raise the dead thus the entire
continent will be facing a horde of
White's over night this theory of mind
has not only been foreshadowed multiple
times throughout the series but it's
also supported with a few visions from
the future diarrhea to come true the
shadow of a dragon flying over King's
Landing and one in which brain sees
King's Landing in winter with an empty
throne room that has its row blown off
the same a denier so in the house of the
undying basically the night king will
create a huge army south while
sacrificing his current army in the
north in that very also introduced with
the death of Cersei Lannister which will
be result of her becoming the met Queen
the one to put an end to Cersei will be
her own little brother Jaime who will
write after that be killed by the
mountain this is a short summary of what
first part look like but if you haven't
already checked the whole thing I highly
suggest you to do so and then come back
to watch this video anyways in this
video we'll be introduced for the deaths
of Daenerys Targaryen Melisandre and the
mountain well start with the death of
infamous Sir Gregor the mountain Clegane
[Music]
remember me yeah you do
you're even [ __ ] uglier than I am now
what do they do to you
doesn't matter it's not how it ends for
you brother
you know is coming for you you've always
known a long anticipated you'll between
the mountain and the hound often
referred to by his fans as cleganebowl
has seemingly been set for the final
season Clegane bull will take place a
few moments are to the death of Cersei
and Jaime Lannister as already said in
part one Jaime upon realizing that
Cersei intends to use välfärd to get rid
of all her enemies including Johnson
Dana's armies that came to save the
capital will have to put an end to this
madness
Jaime already did a huge sacrifice in
order to save hundreds of thousands of
innocent lives by killing the Mad King
and has ever since been called the
Kingslayer however sir civil now intend
to do the same
Jaime is going to kill his sister while
she gives an order to Qyburn - as the
Mad King used to say burn them all Jaime
will do noble sacrifice once again but
this time he will not trade it with his
honor this time it requires his life
Jaime will sacrifice himself by killing
Cersei as the mountain will kill him
immediately in the league scripted says
the Hound brienna riding towards red
keep at a moment of Jaime's huge
argument with Cersei
therefore it's safe to say that the
Hound with Bryan's help will avenge
Amy's death Brienne will arrive in the
throne room with the Hound just at the
time to see the mountain striking down
Jaime that's the moment cool game ball
will take place the Hound will finally
fight and eventually kill his brother in
the duel while Jamie is exhaling his
final breath in Bryans arms this Jaime's
ending has been foreshadowed back in the
fourth episode of the fifth season in
that episode bran asked Jamie how would
he like to die and Jaime responded with
in the arms of the woman I love no two
nights off to rescue a princess
sounds like a good song to me it sounds
like all the rest
what about you what [ __ ] way would you
choose in my own keep you'll get my
online watching the son's grovel from I
thought you how disappointing
I've thought you'd have something more
sizing P and I've had an exciting life
I want my death to be boring now do you
want to go you know I'm
she wants the same thing that woman
would be Breanna anyway send Urkel game
will finally have his justice in the
final season now let's see have Dana's
role in Game of Thrones might end the
most popular fan theory would definitely
be Danny's sacrifice and death in order
to end the long night
both the John and Danny are tied to the
azor Ahai prophecy which includes a
historic legend of a hero sacrificing
his love in order to save the world from
the long night
no Sanjaya already told the nares that
she has her role to play in the prophecy
as does Jon Snow the nurse's role in the
long night but his theory would be her
taking a sword into her heart as a
sacrifice required to win the Great War
however well this theory would most
certainly match with George RR Martin's
announced bittersweet ending I still
believe that a theory of mind that
introduced you with over a year ago will
come true it's Daenerys becoming the
night screen the night screen is an
unseen woman in Game of Thrones a
legendary figure known in the Seven
Kingdoms and among the free folk
according to legend the Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch found in a haunted
forest that called woman with bright
blue eyes he took her to the other side
of the wall and declared himself as the
night's king their love and reign lasted
for 13 years her pond free folk rallied
under the banner of a
king-beyond-the-wall and marched against
the night's king seat against the
Nightfort which resulted Midnight's King
defeat with the aid of House Stark
prior in Game of Thrones we've learned
that the leader of the White Walkers
night King is able to create either
White Walkers but it seems that he can
only create one if that human being is
pure blooded incest born this means that
the night's king could turn Daenerys
into one of them since then his
pure-blooded incest born daughter of
King Aerys and Queen rhaella Targaryen
the only way for the living side to end
the long night is to either defeat them
which would be insanely hard or to make
a pact this pact of Ice and Fire would
include an heiress have you ever
wondered why the night king even coming
south
why was he preparing an army all those
years with which he started marching
south at the moment of the nurses
arrival at Westeros I was wondering
about that ever since the sixth season
ended and I came to a conclusion that
the nearest is arrival at Westeros is
the reason of the night Kings
preparations the reason of his march
south and his reason of every single
death that the Seven Kingdoms is going
to confront
Daenerys could have on the throne as
soon as she arrived at Westeros if she
wanted to not a defeat Cersei you could
storm Kings Landing tomorrow on the city
before hell we almost took it and we
didn't even have dragons
almost but you haven't storm Kings
Landing why not
the only reason I can see is you don't
want to kill thousands of innocent
people it's the fastest way to win the
war but you won't do it which means at
the very least you're better than Cersei
as John stated Danny did not take the
throne yet only because many innocent
people would have died if she had
decided the storm King's Landing
she did not attack King's Landing
because she didn't want to cause death
upon millions of innocent people and she
will not ever sit on the Iron Throne
because she will decide to give up her
life so those people including her child
could live the nurses visions are for
sharing the Dany could easily win the
Iron Throne and sit on it but it also
foreshadows that she will realize that
she will not be able to sit on the same
since she will have to give up on it for
the greater good she will accept a pact
with the knight king in order to end the
long night
Daenerys will become the night's queen
whereupon herself in the night king will
go beyond the wall and rule over it as a
form of peace agreement between the
living and the dead
beside the nurses visions as I've
already said earlier in this video then
his arrival at Westeros and the night
Kings preparations and his march to the
South fits perfectly in the timeline I
don't think it's coincidence that all
those years and 19 was preparing and
gathering huge army with which he
started marching south at the time of
Dana's rival at Westeros
also the fact that the show included
multiple scenes that are proving that
the night king can create other White
Walkers only that human being is a
pure-blooded incest born has to be
foreshadowing something huge to that I
the fact that the nurses in says born
daughter of King Aerys and Queen rhaella
Targaryen and this theory has a huge
chance of coming true not only this
theory will be one of the greatest
surprises that showrunners could pull
out but it will also fit perfectly with
the bittersweet ending the george RR
martin announced the near so in this
theory died in the hands of the night
king as the near soul shortly after
opening her eyes as the night's Queen if
you would like to know all the details
about is the night screen fear if mine
feel free to check out a video by the
name the night king is coming for
Daenerys the final character I will
include in this video and Putin death
list for season 8 is Monsanto if you
don't mind my saying I don't think you
should return to Westeros
I'm not sure you'd be safe here
I will return their Spyder one last time
my lady I have to die in this strange
country let me now introduce with a
prediction regarding both her appearance
and her death let's start with the last
sentence Melisandre said to John you
know the Great War is still to come
you know the arm of the Dead will be
upon us soon and you know I can help you
in that for once Melisandre returns to
Westeros which I expect to happen early
on in the season she most certainly will
not remain south but will go north for
the great war between the living and the
dead will be taking place at this point
of the season taking into consideration
effect that Melisandre has been exiled
from the north no Sanjay will probably
take off her necklace along with her
beauty and youth method and would once
again reveal her true form which is a
frail old woman who is approximately 400
years old no sunshine her true form
would return to Winterfell since no one
has ever seen her true form no one
actually knows how she really looks like
back in the third season Melisandre
prophesied to Arya that they will meet
again one day which might go in favor to
this prediction regarding male Sandra's
reappearance regarding meal Sanjay is
dead there are a couple of possibilities
such as masanjia having to reveal who
she actually is to Jon Snow in order to
commence him into her new prophecies
which would cosmos Sanjay her life
Melisandre veiling who she actually is
the Jon would lead to her death
since Jon promised her that if she is to
return to the north he'll have her
hanged as a killer another possibility
is a prophesied meeting between
Melisandre and Aria which could also
lead to note Sanchez death we know that
area is dedicated on decreasing the
names on her kill list and we also know
that no Sandra's name is on that list
considering all those facts are equally
Melisandre most certainly doesn't seem
to be out of the realm of possibilities
while there are a few ways for
Melisandre to go off one is turn her
scene for season 7 is confirming that
she will not survive the Game of Thrones